all right hi everyone
thank you so much for joining our parent
webinar on how to create a schedule for
your third through 5th grade student as
well as how you can use khan academy
resources and tools to support your
child's learning at home so you can keep
your day moving
i want to take a moment to say thank you
to our sponsors including bank of
america google.org at t and novartis for
helping us provide the support during
school closures
their support has made webinars and
resources like this possible
i also want to acknowledge all you
parents grandparents older siblings and
maybe even some teachers who have joined
us today
thank you for taking the time to learn
more about how you can keep your child
learning at home we are so grateful
you're turning to khan academy during
these challenging times
my name is shannon and i'm a former
teacher currently working on the
district partnerships team at khan
academy i'm so excited to be joined by
two of my colleagues and friends
dan who is on our marketing team
and patty who works with me on the
district partnerships team
patti will be answering your questions
throughout the webinar so please submit
any questions you have throughout the
presentation in the question box and she
will get back to you there and we'll
also save about 10 minutes at the end to
answer your questions live
today's webinar will cover how to find
and utilize content on khan academy
during the school closure period as well
as tips and best practices for setting
up a daily schedule for your child
this will hopefully be helpful to
parents who are looking for ways to keep
their child learning during school
closures and provide some structure so
that you can gain back time in your day
for all the many tasks i'm sure you have
on your list beyond child care and
homeschooling
this webinar will not cover in detail
account setup or how to get started on
khan academy so if you are new our
remote learning guide quick start guide
is a good place to start
if you go to the handout that's linked
in this webinar you will see on the
slide we have linked the quick start
guide so you can check that out there
now for a bit of background on khan
academy we are a non-profit organization
and our mission is to provide a free
world-class education to anyone anywhere
our content is standards align and
available in over 40 languages covering
multiple content areas
your child can access our resources on
the web or through a mobile device
with more than a billion children
worldwide being impacted by school
closures we are experiencing soaring
demand for our free resources
we will continue to produce webinars and
resources to support remote learning so
keep checking back to khan academy.org
for any upcoming webinars and new
resources as they are created
and now let's take a look at what
resources are available for your child
khan academy is possibly best known for
our math content in math videos but in
addition to math we have a full range of
subjects and increasing range of subject
areas for your elementary school student
relevant content might include our
english language arts content which is
in a work in progress state you can
expect to see it change and evolve as we
continue to gather feedback
we also have a mastery enabled grammar
course which covers third through fifth
grade grammar standards a computer
animation and storytelling course
both of these courses were created in
partnership with disney and pixar and
are highly creative they involve
computer based and tech free activities
we also have a computer programming for
beginners course
and growth mindset activities for all
ages
these activities offer students an
opportunity to reflect on their learning
goals and develop learning strategies
that will likely benefit them as they
adjust to their new learning routine at
home
of our third through fifth grade content
one important thing to note is only math
and grammar are mastery enabled
meaning students can work through an
entire year's worth of content and
at their own pace track their progress
along the way
you might be wondering well how do i
access this content and the first step
is to ensure that your child is logged
in to their khan academy account
and from there as you can see on the
right side
you go up to courses
and that will bring you to a menu
displaying all content on khan academy
and your students can access any
exercises quizzes unit tests from there
but you have another option on your
child's home page they can select edit
courses to access content and one
benefit to adding courses this way is
it'll automatically recommend courses
based off their grade level so you can
easily find what content is relevant for
your child and once they've selected and
saved those courses they will always
appear on their home page so it'll be
easy to access for them
and during this time of school closures
we've heard so much feedback and
questions from parents and teachers
about how to structure a student's day
and keep their child learning while
still getting your own work done we know
how challenging it can be to juggle
multiple priorities and we hope that our
resources can help you achieve some
semblance of normalcy during this time
and in response to this feedback we
created this set of schedules that give
you a recommendation
or you can think of it as a starting
point restructuring your day
using the link on this page you will see
a template for the daily schedules which
go all the way from pre-k to high school
so if you have younger students or older
students you can see the schedules there
we put these schedules out having heard
that there was a need but it's important
to acknowledge that they won't just work
as is for all families
you know your child best so we encourage
you to adapt and change the schedule to
make it work for you and your child
in our sample schedule which you see
here the subjects outlined in green have
resources available for your child on a
khan academy
your child's school might already be
providing remote learning guidance or
tools
or the schedule might not work well with
the routine you've already established
so know our sample schedules are meant
to be flexible and adaptable to meet the
needs of your family
you might not be able to stick to the
schedule every day and that's more than
okay
during these challenging times everyone
is just trying to do their best so if
all you can do is an hour of math and an
hour of reading a day with your child
that's great and that's enough
when you and your child are ready
you can always add additional subjects
or activities that might interest your
child
for a quick run-through of the sample
schedule we have here
we'll start our day with breakfast
followed by math
some outdoor play if possible or maybe a
board game with a sibling
followed by english language arts
some silent reading time
grammar and then end the day with some
fun enrichment activities
now we're going to go through each part
of this schedule and talk about what
resources you might use from khan
academy
so starting our day like i mentioned
first thing to do is eat some breakfast
the most important meal of the day and
get out of your pajamas it's time to get
started with math and depending on your
child's grade level
second through fifth grade math is
likely a good place for them to get
started
to move through the content more quickly
students can utilize our course
challenges and unit tests
one practice we've seen effective to
fill in learning gaps that your child
may have developed over the years
is to have students start at
kindergarten and work through the
content for each grade level before
moving on to the next
this provides students a rare
opportunity to fill in those gaps that
might hold them back in the future
if your child doesn't have too many gaps
they can typically get through previous
years content in one to three hours
for a quick overview of our math content
here are the most important things you
need to know
our math content is aligned to common
core standards
and it covers all standards from
kindergarten up to early college
all math content is mastery enabled so
students can work through an entire
course at their own pace
as your child works through a course
they will be exposed to various question
types receive instant feedback
and if they get stuck they have access
to step-by-step solutions videos and
articles
so before asking you for help encourage
them to check out the learning resources
that are built into khan academy
students can also track their progress
on each course on this course in real
time and as a parent you can track their
progress on your parent dashboard
we recommend giving students ample time
to play and get their heart pumping
after a break students can jump into our
english language arts content you can
expect to see more content added to each
grade level over the next month
you can have your child start at grade
level and practice one to two practice
sets per day which should take about 20
minutes
if you notice the content is too easy or
too challenging for your child you can
have them move up or down at any time
an relay content is aligned to common
core standards right now our content
includes practice for second through
eighth grade standards with ninth grade
coming soon
the content is focused on reading and
vocabulary standards
as students work through assignments
they will be exposed to interesting
passage topics related to science social
studies and social emotional learning
similar to our math content students
have access to instant feedback and a
worked rationale for every answer choice
if they get stuck
are you our english language arts
courses have a limited number of videos
but you can expect to see more added
soon
another option for your child during the
english language arts block
is to check out our project based
imagineering in a box course
in this exciting course made in
partnership with disney
students will create a theme park of
their very own by getting a
behind-the-scenes look at how artists
designers and engineers come together to
create theme parks
the course includes videos and articles
and activities such as designing a menu
creating a ride simulator and building a
prototype character
the course is broken down into three
main lessons with each lesson taking a
minimum of two hours
so one option if you want to implement
this course with your child is to have
them work through the lessons for about
30 minutes one to two days per week in
place of their english language arts
content
and now we have arrived at silent
reading time which your child is likely
used to having in their regular school
day
we have listed
popular books by grade level you can see
the link here but encourage you to have
your child find something that they're
interested in
now after silent reading you can take a
quick walk or break
and then your child can jump into our
grammar content
we recommend having your students start
by taking the course challenge a few
times to figure out what they know and
what skills they still need to work on
and similar to our math content our
grammar course is also mastery enabled
so your child can work through the
skills at their own pace and track their
progress along the way
the course covers skills related to
third through fifth grade standard
american english standards and every
question has a step-by-step solution and
a line video to help support students as
they work through the skills
then for some tech free time which is so
important have your child take some time
to journal or respond to a writing
prompt this could be as simple as having
them write about their day
and how they're feeling or you can have
them create a story of their very own
on the schedule you'll see some sample
writing problems you can pull from but
feel free to make these up on your own
or encourage your child to make up a
prompt
you can follow up writing time with some
lunch and maybe an educational podcast
podcasts are a great way to keep your
child learning while reducing their time
spent staring at a computer screen and
it also might give you back a bit of
time
there are a ton of great podcasts for
kids available and we've listed some
examples but encourage students to find
something that they're interested in
and we'll end the day with enrichment
some options include code.org express
course which is the block based coding
for beginners course where students will
create their very own story or game
and on khan academy we also have a
text-based computer programming course
computer animation course which was
created in partnership with pixar and
growth mindset activities for elementary
school students
if you have an upper elementary school
student so a fourth or fifth grader or
maybe you have a middle or high school
student and they're interested in
computer animation you can try our
interactive computer animation course
the course demonstrates how traditional
school subjects such as math science and
the arts are a vital part of the
everyday work put into pixar's
filmmaking process
in this course students will work
through the many stages of the
filmmaking process including lighting
effects and set and staging
similar to other content on khan academy
students within this course have access
to instant feedback on exercises
step-by-step solutions for every
question they answer and instructional
videos to guide them along the way
this content spans multiple grade levels
so not every lesson is appropriate for
your fourth or fifth grader but within
the course you can access a lesson
finder and find content that's relevant
for your age for whatever grade level or
age your child is
and lastly our research-based growth
mindset activities are especially
relevant during this challenging time of
school closures the activities provide a
structured way for students to explore
the science behind their brain and the
idea that they can learn anything
the growth mindset videos and articles
and activities cover topics such as the
brain and learning how to work through
mistakes and frustration
and how to set goals
with students adjusting to their new
remote learning routine these activities
will provide a way for students to
process and reflect on their new normal
and set goals for learning remotely
and if you're just getting started with
remote learning with your child and are
looking for more tips and best practices
to support them and their learning
see the link for more information we
held a webinar last week that covered a
lot of tips for effective remote
learning so it might be worthwhile to
check out
and again i just want to say thank you
so much for joining us after what i'm
sure was a long day and i'll be turning
it over to patty and dan for live q a so
if you have any further questions you
can reach out um in the chat box for the
next 10 minutes uh but if you have any
questions after that reach out to our
help center and feel free to share this
presentation with any other parents who
might find it helpful thank you so much
thank you shannon hi everyone i'm dan
and i'll be moderating the live q a
portion of this session
and thank you patty for joining me patty
gets to do the hard work of actually
providing the answers
before we get to the live question
section please do two things for us um
first go to the handout section of this
webinar you can download the pdf version
of this presentation it contains
guidance through the entire process that
shannon just walked through so it has a
great overview of all the content both
from the core courses that we have of
math ela but also some of the other
things that create a mix for your
students and kids basically you know the
pixar course is really fun the computer
animation courses the computer
programming courses and it also has
links to resources that we built
specifically for school closures
including recommended reading lists
writing prompts
and links to other useful resources and
of course the suggested schedules and
framework that shannon just walked you
through and the second that we the thing
that we'd asked you to do is please if
you have any questions add them to the
question box
and we can get started with
the live portion of the q a
so let's go ahead um
patty we have a question from tracy so
tracy says hello thank you for having
this webinar please tell me is this um
math content common core based and then
also stephanie is asking is the
curriculum based off of school districts
and or state expectations i think
they're both speaking to standards
alignment
yeah thanks so much dan and as well
tracy and stephanie and everyone for
being here with us today
so at a large level our math content is
common core based it is aligned to the
common core state standards and so when
you think about that that second
question that stephanie asked is it
based off of school district or state
expectations if your state which is
currently most states use common core
standards then it would be aligned to
the same standards that your child or
your student is going to be learning in
school
great
um and then i think here's a question
from sharon
this is a great question because i think
a lot of folks probably don't really
understand this please explain what
mastery enabled means
yes so mastery is something that at khan
academy we're really passionate about
and one of the reasons we're passionate
about it is because there are many
research studies that have showed that
students being able to learn a
particular skill
and become fluent at it and then also
have long-term retention meaning that if
they come back to that same skill after
a specific amount of time and they're
able to show that they still know that
skill that means they've mastered that
skill and so when we think about mastery
and what shannon was talking about
mastery enabled it means that the
mechanism of getting to that fluency and
that long-term retention
the course um allows you to be able to
kind of see the progress that a student
might make and so if you're a little bit
familiar with khan academy if you're not
yet that's okay that's why we're here
the mastery enabled system has different
levels and so a student gets to go you
know for a particular skill you can
think about uh understanding area
potentially for that fifth grade kiddo
they are going to first be at not
attempted right they maybe don't know
anything about area quite yet and then
if they practice this skill the first
time they might get to familiar right
maybe they got some questions right
maybe they got some questions wrong but
they have some sort of level of
familiarity with area with how to find
the area and then from there the next
time that student goes and tries that
same skill to try to demonstrate that
they know area maybe they get all the
questions correct and so they get to
proficiency they get to a certain level
they are aware of what area is and where
mastery comes in is that as i mentioned
long-term retention so student is then
able to come back show that they still
know
how to find the area of a particular
object which means that they would get
to mastered so mastery enabled in short
is the mechanism that we use on khan
academy to be able to show a student's
progress to get to a really really
strong level of mastering a particular
skill
and you can learn more about that too
sorry uh dan in uh we have various
resources even right now if you open
your browser and google like khan
academy mastery learning system there's
a really nice uh help center article
that will pop up to help you kind of get
more familiar with the levels as you're
supporting your student your child uh
with some of this learning
so very much related to that we have a
question from carla jodi who asks one of
my children is in first grade another is
in fourth but he's doing second grade
math should we start with first grade in
con and go through the assessments she
just mentioned or shannon just mentioned
i guess then go to second or to start at
second grade so i think this is really
perfectly aligned to what you just
mentioned in terms of math in terms of
mastery
yeah of course
so carla and jody you know thinking
about where to get a student started
where do you where to get your child
started we've seen various different
tactics that work
we've worked with some districts there
was one district in pennsylvania that we
worked with that actually started the
entire district you can imagine their
elementary school they all started at
the kindergarten level and so what was
really cool is that they were able to
make progress through the mastery system
at their own pace so if there was a
student you know that spent maybe a
couple hours on kindergarten and then
moved to first and so on it made sure
that they had a consistent set of
knowledge as they were nearing let's say
third grade if that was the grade they
were in or as they were nearing fifth
grade if that was the grade that we're
in
so i would say you know depending on how
familiar you are with your students uh
current grasp of either the second grade
math content or
the second grade math content
let them maybe try out um that content
like start them at their grade level and
if it seems like they're struggling a
little bit
maybe i would say have them restart with
first grade and if they go through it
quickly that's great um or if maybe you
know they're taking it slow and they
want to be really really effective and
make sure they're getting to mastered on
all the skills that might again make
sure to fill in any gaps that they might
have from the previous grade level
standards so i would say let your
student maybe you know try it out see
how they're handling it
and then if for some reason they need a
little bit more support you can always
go back to the previous grade level i
personally i was a middle school math
teacher um and by the time students come
to middle school right all different
types of various experiences i was
always a big fan of spending a little
bit of time reviewing um and on the math
side i really think it's helpful for
kiddos to feel confident and have some
early wins
yeah and patty i would add you know tim
vandenberg who's a teacher who's been
working with um jeremy on our teacher
webinars you know his advice is to start
from kindergarten you know regardless of
what what grade you're in and um you
know i think that gets over the stigma
because everyone's starting at
kindergarten and then getting practice
and building up um their skill set while
kind of filling in the swiss cheese gaps
that sal always talks about um so i
don't think there's anything wrong with
starting earlier if that's helpful but
obviously every every student and every
child is going to
be going at their own pace and i think
that's one of the great things that khan
academy does is it helps you move you
along if you're already there it helps
fills in gaps if you have some gaps as
well so i think there's plenty of
options available
yep that's great
um so pat we have a question from
pradeep any questions there any specific
device to you chromebook laptop or can
an ipad be sufficient
that's a great question pretty
you can use any of those and also any
sort of smartphone or
browser that is available to you on a
mobile device so if you you know if your
student i would say or child is used to
using a chromebook
maybe go with that right especially if
they do have a chromebook at home
potentially their district gave them to
them
or if they're more comfortable with an
ipad then maybe go with that option
and if potentially you have multiple
children at home
you can also always you know alternate
potentially what a device you have
available but really khan academy
including our uh younger
tool which is khan kids
available
con kids specifically through the ipad
because it's an app
but khan academy and everything that
shannon discussed you can use any of
those so chromebook laptop ipad mobile
phone
perfect
and then tamara asks can i add my
daughter's account from school to her
home account
yes so this is where if you know
depending on the email address that your
student is using at school versus the
email address they're using at home they
might have two separate accounts but the
cool thing is for you as a parent you
can have visibility into either
so we have as part of our resources a
quick start guide how to get started as
a parent so once you download if you
haven't yet the slides for this webinar
i would look through there in that last
section to be able to see one of the
parent quick starts guides on how you
can
either add your daughter's school
account or your daughter's home account
so you have visibility to both as a
parent
great
so shawna asks once you do a course
challenge do you go back and complete
each sections of work or if you have a
score do you move on to the challenge in
the next grade level
yeah shauna i think um this is a great
question often one we get from teachers
in thinking about you know when is the
right time to move a student through on
to the next course potentially or also
the next unit
so when it comes to the course challenge
i would say you know if your
student child gets through that and gets
every single question correct
i would say the threshold usually we you
know if they get everything correct then
that student is showing that for the
skills in that particular course
they're they're proficient right like
they are pretty solid they have a very
strong solid foundation they comprehend
what is happening
and from there
i would say moving them on
is a good idea just letting them again
go through the second course and moving
on to the next course
if for some reason that student i would
say the threshold where we kind of pause
a little bit is if they get below an 80
percent so after the course challenge if
they don't have the proficiency grasp on
80 of the course course content
then it's a really good idea to have
that student go through each unit again
they might move a little bit faster
through some units in that course they
might move a little bit slower through
some units in this course that is
totally okay
but we want to make sure again like dan
mentioned earlier that we're really not
letting any of those gaps form and so
students are really able to progress
through content at a pace that makes
sense for them
and so
check in a little bit see see how the
course challenge goes and kind of figure
that out based on their score for that
perfect thank you patty so we have a
question from micah um most schedules
begin with math at the beginning of the
day is there significance to this order
of math being first in the day
yeah so this this is a great question
and of course i
must admit as a former math teacher i
might have some bias here
and i think as uh many con folks being
very fond of math i think um essentially
you know
at the at the beginning of the day your
mind is typically the most fresh and
when we think about students right who
are traditionally going to school at a
certain time so we want to kind of
mirror that same ability for students to
have a really fresh mind to really dive
deeper into the core subjects at the
beginning of the day and so we know one
of the core subjects is obviously math
they just had breakfast hopefully you
know they're ready to learn um which is
why essentially we put math towards the
beginning of the day and that's what we
recommend
yeah perfect so i think we have time for
one more question i can answer this and
you can chime in as well patty uh pamela
do we need to uh pamela asks do we need
a subscription to khan academy to access
any or all of the materials on khan
academy or is this entirely free
so i would say this is entirely free uh
you need we ask for a subscription
there's no subscriptions you basically
need an email account to log in so that
we can track progress and we can serve
you know um and serve you the
appropriate you know the materials but
we're 100 free for parents teachers and
uh and and students
any anything you want to add there patty
no i think i think you said it right dan
we're committed to being able to support
all of you and being able to share all
the wealth of resources and content that
we have for free
so i think that's all the time we have
for live questions so thanks shannon for
presenting and thank you patty for
answering all of the questions and then
i wanted to thank you the audience for
taking the time out of your busy
evenings to be with us we know this is
an extremely busy time for all of you
and we appreciate
you investing your time into this
session um if you missed anything or if
you want to go back and review for those
of you who registered this recording
will automatically be emailed to you
once it gets posted and then for those
of you who um might know of other folks
who would be interested in this we'll be
making this available and posted online
for reference um and then also we have
quite a few other resources that we're
building on a daily basis for you all
and this is available at khanacademy.org
so please come back and visit often
we're building things like i said daily
uh for you all and then before we sign
off we'd ask you to do one more thing
for us there's a poll that pops up at
the very end of this webinar
and we would like you to give us
feedback on two things first how could
we make future iterations of this
session even better for you all and then
secondly what kind of sessions would you
like to see from us next
in fact this session was actually
structured and created based on feedback
from the first session we created many
of you asked for more insights in terms
of scheduling and finding content and so
i just want to let you all know that
we're listening we're here to support
you and your feedback is very welcome
and we try to incorporate it in
everything that we do um so thank you
for that and in closing we just want you
to know that we recognize you're
juggling a lot as parents as you know
guardians as grandparents as well as
nannies i saw somebody post a call for
nannies in the questions um this is
uncharted territory for all of us and we
here at khan academy we want to remind
you that it's really important that you
be kind to yourselves in this period um
there's lots happening and you're
juggling work you're juggling parenting
and you're juggling education all at the
same time and so we're here to support
you and we want you to be kind to
yourselves and we want you to know that
we recognize that you've got this this
is going to be something that you're
going to do very well
and so with that from all of us at khan
academy you know thanks again and good
night